et on vous êtes réélu largement avec 62%
des suffrages
il me semble que c'est le meilleur
résultat aussi du second tour
je crois qu'il est dans la ligne du
résultat du premier tour donc des
défections je sais pas une réflexion
globale oui au vu du taux d'abstention
pour tous les camps politiques
voilà donc comment vous l'analysez parce
que au-delà d'abstention le score à la
fois du parti socialiste et du parti des
républicains montrent que les français
veulent tourner une page en tout cas
d'un grande claque aux partis politiques
traditionnels
oui mais sans adhérer pour autant
complètement à la nouveauté
il ya déjà vous savez les gens
constituer sur un peu fantasque et il
jette assez vite être plus en plus vite
ce qu'ils ont adoré à jour est donc déjà
sans doute qu'il ya de la méfiance de
l'intérêt certes par rapport à cette
nouvelle majorité de l'espérance c'est
vrai aussi mais sans doute sans excès et
que voilà je pense que c'est bien
d'ailleurs ne pas commencer avec des
taux de popularité comme un inconnu avec
les nouveaux présidents qui
s'effritaient très rapidement et de
commencer pas trop et de faire ses
preuves progressivement et décide
surtout de se réconcilier drake aussi de
la politique avec les citoyens ça c'est
une large affaires large à faire et vous